diese polizisten in ägypten hatten
eigentlich den auftrag eine bank zu
bewachen
doch dann machte eine passantin sie auf
einen kleinen jungen aufmerksam der an
einem wohnungs balkon hängen und drohte
abzustürzen
genau so kam es auch einer der
polizisten konnte den jungen auffangen
nach angaben des ägyptischen
innenministeriums konnten die eltern ihr
kind unversehrt in die arme schließen
die mutter bedankte sich bei der polizei
für ihren einsatz
wie der junge in die schwierige lage
kommen konnte war zunächst nicht bekannt
der polizist der ihn aufgefangen hatte
soll bei seiner rettungstat leicht im
gesicht verletzt worden sein